So this is the model that we started with.
There's a compartment of susceptible persons, a compartment of infectious persons,
and a compartment of recovered persons.
Depending on the number of infectious persons, susceptible persons become infectious,
and infectious persons automatically recover after awhile.
Now, we're introducing another effect latency.
Persons who get infected should not immediately become infectious and we model this
by introducing another compartment--exposed persons.
Depending on the number of infectious persons and susceptible persons,
susceptible persons become exposed--that is infected and after awhile, become infectious.
This should obviously be called the SEIR model.